Please welcome one of my favorite humans,
Gabrielle Union.
(audience cheering)
Hello, I'm so happy to be here.
I did wanna get your take.
The Oscars are this weekend,
and we've been just talking about this, and your pal,
Regina Hall is co-hosting
and I'm so Interested to hear your take on this.
Are you gonna watch, have you talked to her?
What's the 4-1-1?
No, I want her to be able to have this experience
and not be pressured by all of us, like you better tell it.
I am beyond proud of her and yeah,
I'm just proud and I can't wait to give her a massive hug
after she kills it.
I also am so excited.
I feel like this is like Will Smith's year
and I know you co-starred with him in "Bad Boys 2".
And you know him, I did you see this coming?
What are your thoughts?
I hope, you know, I hope, you know
when you do the work and it's so beautiful
and it's so well received
and you really have shed a different kind of light
on the journey of two of the greatest athletes of all time
and Will did such an amazing job.
So you hope, I mean, and as an academy voter,
I mean, I don't wanna tip my hand too much,
but I am hopeful that this is Will's year.
I totally agree, it is time.
And speaking of time, back in the day you attended UCLA?
Yes, I'm a Bruin.
And what were you studying while you were there?
I was a sociology major and the plan was to
take the LSATs, become a defense attorney
and that was gonna be my life.
And things changed, I got an internship at a modeling agency
and then the next thing I know they were like,
would you ever wanna do this?
And I'm like, no acting and modeling, they're not real jobs,
cut to turns out they're real jobs.
And I've been making my living as an actor
for all of these years.
But until you actually walk in the shoes of an actor
or a model or whatever you have no idea what goes into,
you know why they do what they do
or why they're good at it or not.
You're talking about walking in an actor's shoes.
And I found this story, you were on Star Trek?
Yes, yes, one of my first gigs.
I was on Star Trek Deep Space 9,
not I played Worf's daughter.
Yeah, it was a fun, random, long experience.
I didn't know how long it took
to put all that makeup on every day.
And it didn't dawn on me that, you know,
when you break for lunch, you still have all of it on.
And everyone's like leaving to go to lunch.
And they're like, oh, join us over at Lucy's,
which is this amazing Mexican restaurant
across from Paramount.
So I'm literally, cut to
I'm walking down Melrose as a Klingon,
I walk into Lucy's and they're like chips and salsa?
And I'm like,
is no one gonna acknowledge that I am a Klingon?
If you need a visual, 'cause I wanted one
of you as a Klingon, take a look.
There may be more hostile simulation programs out there.
(laughter)
(audience cheering)
Now I love always to talk like girl talk with you
and love, it's my favorite subject.
You and Dwayne, you guys have been married for seven years.
(audience cheering)
And you have such a beautiful, loving,
couple goals relationship.
And I didn't know this,
but there is something about the genius musical icon
known as Prince,
that maybe played a part in how you and Dwayne met.
Is this true?
This is true to a degree.
So Prince used to host these epic parties
after awards shows.
So I was with my girlfriends.
I think it was like going up in this elevator.
It was like Nia Long and Vanessa Lachey.
Oh my God.
And we're going up
this elevator and these two guys get on and they're like,
oh my God, you know, Dwayne Wade's our brother,
would you ever wanna host party with him?
I was like, yeah, whatever, let me look up who this kid is.
But that was it, and then we proceeded up to Prince's house
and had the time of our lives.
And eventually I ended up doing a party with Dwayne
and the rest is kind of history
That just has all the (kisses) on it
you could ever hope for.
(upbeat music)